as you guys know it's very important
March we just got out of Black History
Month was February and I celebrated
every day this is women's what is it
women's history month are we calling it
are we calling it International women's
month
and Hershey which I thought their whole
thing was about making good chocolate
they put out this incredible ad to
celebrate the moment my name is Faye
Johnstone I'm the executive director of
wisdom to action we can create a world
where everyone is able to live in public
space as their honest and authentic
selves see the woman changing how we see
the future at Hershey's Canada
Libby will do women first she's a dude
man Chick yeah I mean what
She's a Man baby for real yeah so Canada
is totally off the rails it's not even a
real country it's totally fake place at
this point you know just to be clear
this came from Canada's Hershey
subsidiary or whatever yeah because it
has a two at the beginning of the LGBT
alphabet soup and the two is for two
spirit
um which I don't know how it's not
cultural appropriation to put that in
your very Western weird thing but what
have you Justin Trudeau knows and we all
just have to count on that yeah I'm
personally very sick and tired of men
standing up there with long hair and
makeup on and telling me they know
better than anyone else than any woman
what it is to be a woman I'm sick of
empowering a whole bunch of essentially
straight white men to uh get up there
and tell us that they're women uh while
they claim to be lesbians and demand
access to all sorts of women's spaces
the whole thing is so marvelously insane
that I think a lot of people when they
first started seeing this coming around
the bend just thought that's so
obviously stupid that can't be the way
that we're going with these kinds of
things and now it is now here it is oh
but weekend James can you please put
this chick in her place as a woman
yourself
yeah you gotta like settle down here for
this month Libby
um like just yeah just hold up uh well
what I see is a chocolate bar that's got
nuts in it that's not being advertised
as having nuts in it but maybe people
have peanut allergies you never know I
got it I got it yeah right
um so I mean that dude has a vocal fry
down I wish I could do that uh that's a
woman thing if we can celebrate in woman
month is vocal fry septum piercing no
but what we see is the complete
inversion of reality what we see is
another opportunity as as you saw to
talk about
reality in upside down world this is
your authentic self she called or he
called it called itself authentic self
literally pretending to be what you're
not literally demanding people celebrate
and affirm you for what you're not and
that's actually the magic formula it
starts off with we should tolerate this
it progresses to we have to accept this
it goes beyond that and we have to now
celebrate it and then at some point we
have to participate in it to some degree
we have to participate in the LIE we
have to participate in the delusion if
you don't want to eat the the nuts no
nuts chocolate bar you're probably a
bigot if you don't want this man in a
woman's space you're definitely a bigot
if you aren't interested in his uh lady
thing you are as a woman you are
definitely transphobic and you make all
of your sexual decisions and personal
decisions in your life based on genitals
and how disgusting in crass you are
of course what we see throughout is just
projection if you'd like more sane takes
on our insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell